I will simply never have time to read
all of the non-fiction books I'd like to
read so I use short form the world's
best guide to non-fiction books so I can
learn more faster unlike other platforms
short form provides valuable analysis
chapter by chapter to give you a deeper
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
I have incredible economic data to start
today with and I tell you these jobs
numbers not because they are the proof
that everything Joe Biden has done has
been correct these numbers are not proof
that Biden has fixed the systemic and
structural issues with our economy which
include inequality and so many other
things which we talk about all the time
I give you these numbers so that you
understand that by the same metrics that
Republicans use to judge their
presidents the economy is doing fine now
fine doesn't mean there will never be a
recession fine doesn't mean some people
are unemployed fine means there is no
great alarm sounding of an imminent
Biden induced recession let's first talk
about the data 497
000 jobs added in June you might say
well I don't know
340 335 million people in the United
States is 497 000 new jobs in June
remarkable it's remarkable in the sense
that the estimate was that there would
only be 220 000 jobs added in June and
the real number 497
000 is more than double that more than
double that uh this is also
significantly more than the 267 000 jobs
that were added in May the leading
um uh industries were Leisure and
Hospitality some say Leisure I know
people who say Leisure and Hospitality
either way these are jobs paid in US
Dollars no matter what pronunciation you
use 232
000 of that 497 was Leisure and
hospitality
nearly a hundred thousand jobs in
construction trade transportation and
utilities at ninety thousand also
interesting when it comes to
construction this is an industry that
when you talk to to random people who
were supporters of Maga in uh Trump's
first term they would say construction
is booming under Trump and uh we really
think construction is an important
leading economic indicator when you see
more construction jobs you know that in
the future if it's commercial offices
that are being built those will
eventually be filled with tenants so
that's a leading indicator for a good
economy when you're talking about houses
single-family homes and condos when you
see construction jobs it means
single-family houses and condos are
being built and thus eventually when
those are those are built they will sell
and you will have people buying them
that these are leading indicators they
said under Trump we are seeing
construction uh jobs growing
significantly so what is the takeaway
here the takeaway is not one about we
now have a perfect economy we've solved
every problem we've ever had when it
comes to wages and employment and all of
these different things the point here is
that the right-wing media and
politicians are trying to spread a false
narrative
that narrative is that the Biden economy
is terrible and it's because of Joe
Biden and it is Joe Biden's policies
that have hurt the American people and
it's increasingly difficult to do this
we played a clip for you a few shows ago
of Larry Kudlow a former Trump economic
advisor appearing on Fox News and being
asked by the fox host listen the setup
was something like go check it out for
the exact wording but it was something
like we see all of these economic
indicators they look so good but explain
like why is the economy actually not so
good and Larry Kudlow was unable to do
so he said something about Ai and
Technology it was pathetic he failed to
make that case and so what Republicans
in the right have been relegated to is
cherry picking data ignoring context
distorting facts ignoring history to try
to undermine what is a very solid
economy
that happens to be taking place when Joe
Biden is President and is doing some
good things it's really important to
remember you know if you want shows that
play politics with this economic data
you can go and find them I don't know
which they are I certainly don't watch
them but you can go and find those shows
when we talk about economic data uh and
we talk about economies in general I try
to be crystal clear with you that most
of what we see is not directly related
to what the president does for example
inflation is coming down in just about
every Western wealthy industrialized
Nation whatever term you want to use
what we call the oecd countries
inflation has been coming down in all of
those uh countries so it's not because
of Biden that inflation is coming down
but inflation has been coming down
slightly faster in the United States
than in some of those other countries
and we can certainly point to some Biden
policies like the inflation reduction
act which are influencing that inflation
would be coming down anyway
but we can argue that the Biden policy
by Dynamics is helping that along
similarly
job creation we are seeing job creation
in many Western oecd countries but we
can say that what Joe Biden has done is
making that job creation a little more
robust than if we had for example Trump
policy in place it's also really
important to remember when we look at
the economy that economies don't
perfectly overlap in terms of their
movements with presidential terms it is
true that if you look back at the last
100 years or 120 years it is true that
we tend to see higher job creation when
there's a democrat in the white house we
tend to see better stock market
performance when a Democrat is in the
white house we see lower unemployment
when a Democrat is in the white house we
see lower inflation when a Democrat is
in the white house we see higher GDP
when a Democrat is in the White House
these are averages but it is not perfect
it is not perfectly aligned and so we
had Joe Biden coming in during the
covid-19 recovery
uh we had
um the American Rescue plan put in place
all of these different things and the
the timing of these economic movements
will not perfectly align for example we
started to see gas prices go up at the
end of Trump's term they continued going
up during Joe Biden then they started
coming down is one or the other
specifically to blame for those
movements no and so those are the types
of political games I try to avoid uh
playing with you the other thing is it's
important to look more broadly at some
of the other macroeconomic things that
are going on uh and again these are
going on globally the gloomy picture
that the right is trying to paint of the
American economy not only has to be done
by removing all context from the United
States economy but it also has to be
done by ignoring broadly what is
happening again in the western wealthy
industrialized oecd countries they are
all doing relatively well and that makes
it even harder to believe data aside
right if you would nor the data that
says things are looking okay
it's harder to believe that things are
uniquely bad in the U.S when we see a
generally positive trend in most of
these Western economies so we're going
to continue following these numbers the
bottom line is this is not a terrible
economy it's a pretty good economy it's
interesting that Joe Biden has been able
to actually get done as much as he has
uh uh given the level of opposition that
Republicans have put forward and I would
actually go further the economy would
likely be even better were it not for
the obstruction of Republicans many of
whom voted against the things that Joe
Biden tried to do and has been able to
do but now want credit for them as we
talked about last week let's talk about
political fundraising we've been looking
at polling but we have not been looking
at fundraising the second quarter just
ended the second quarter is April May
and June and we have some very
interesting new fundraising data I do
not yet have Joe Biden's fundraising
data for the second quarter when I have
it I will tell you what it is
but Donald Trump's fundraising has
exploded significantly in Q2 assuming of
course that the Trump campaign is being
honest in their reporting Trump pulled
in per Politico more than 35 million
dollars in the second quarter
that is nearly double what Trump raised
in q1 and suggests political rights that
the indictments are helping with
fundraising and the article goes into
detail in q1 Trump raised just under 19
million dollars in Q2 Trump raised more
than 35 million dollars important to
note The Joint fundraising committee is
split between Trump's official campaign
and his leadership packs save America at
least in theory the save America Pac is
meant to raise money for people that
Trump endorses or supports
um the official did not break down how
much of that 35 million went to Trump
versus the PAC but the most recent
fundraising solicitations direct 90
percent of each donation to Trump's
campaign and 10 to the save America pack
the pack by the way also lately is
focusing spending on non-campaign
activity like paying for Trump Trump's
legal bills so there are a few different
things to talk about here first and
foremost the average donation was 34.20
we have people
who can only afford to give about 30
bucks
paying for a billionaires legal fees a
billionaire who has a private jet they
are sending money to a guy with a
private plane for his legal fees because
of all of the crimes he allegedly
committed and all they can really do is
30 bucks because statistically they
can't meet an unexpected 400 expense
that they might be presented with
that's insane that is insane and grift
after grift you know I hate to do this
sort of like uh Caveat Emptor a fool in
their money or soon parted we can't have
a nanny State protecting these people
like I I don't want to go in that
direction but after the grift of 2016
where Trump raised money money despite
saying I don't really need any money I'm
rich enough to run on my own with all of
these promises that he didn't meet
and then he ran again in 2020 saying I'm
making the same promises all over again
even though I didn't meet them in the
first campaign this time I will and
people donate and then Trump loses and
then Trump says Hey Now I need your
money in order to overturn elections and
do forensic audits where we're going to
look ballot by ballot for bamboo fibers
or barbecue sauce or or whatever the
case they were looking for and also for
filing lawsuits and then half of that 70
of that went to paying Trump's campaign
bills grift after grift after grift and
now he's doing it again and they're
still donating money for legal fees
um at this point I don't think there's
anyone who can protect these people and
probably we shouldn't even continue
trying I want to hear from you on that
question should these folks who continue
to donate money to the obvious grift
should we even care at this point or at
some point is it a matter of personal
responsibility like Republicans love to
say and they need to be parted with
their money if they are going to fall
for it again let me know what you think
we are going to keep an eye on the Biden
fundraising numbers also as far as
fundraising this is a very interesting
report from axios from yesterday
called Democrats amass early War chest
for brutal 2024 Senate map uh the 2024
Senate map is not a great map for
Democrats remember that with a hundred
senators in the Senate every two years a
third of them are up for re-election the
terms are six years long but these are
sort of overlapping classes in the
Senate the third of the Senate that
happens to be up for reelection in 2024
is not particularly good for Democrats
what is very interesting is that a
number of uh a number of prominent
Democrats are doing really well in terms
of fundraising Senator Bob Casey in
Pennsylvania has raised more than four
million dollars that's his best
fundraising quarter ever senator Tammy
Baldwin from Wisconsin first openly LGBT
woman in the Senate raised over three
million dollars that is also a record
high Adam Schiff broke the record for a
second quarter Senate fundraising
remember he's a member of Congress but
he's running for Dianne Feinstein's seat
which he will be vacating these are
stunning stunning stunning numbers but
there are many Republicans who are doing
well as well in Nevada retired U.S army
Captain Sam Brown uh is likely to launch
a senate uh campaign
against the Democrat there and that
potentially is going to uh do well in
terms of uh fundraising there are
Republicans who have the potential with
major Republican Senate campaign support
to also do well but the encouraging sign
here is
it
right now
if we want a proxy to enthusiasm for
2024 we would look at fundraising I
don't have the Biden Q2 numbers but I do
have some Senate Q2 numbers and they
look very good particularly considering
that it's July of the year before the
election hope is not lost and the Senate
could end up being okay in 2024 that's
where we'll leave it we'll take a quick
break after this I am going to talk
about threads the new Twitter competitor
we're going to talk about so many
different things glad you're with us
today
when there's a non-fiction book I just
don't have the time to read having a
summary of the book is really valuable
several different platforms out there
will summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below
I want to welcome all of our new podcast
listeners the reason I mentioned that
specifically is that we just got the
June numbers and they are super strong
even Trump's pollster McLachlan would
have to admit that these are very very
good numbers 825
000 podcast downloads in June uh that's
the best month we've ever had in the
history of the show and we're pushing
towards a million a month as far as
podcast downloads and I want to welcome
everybody who has found us through the
audio podcast I also want to remind you
we are primarily a funded by the
audience program you can get a
membership at joinpakman.com I won't
bore you with the details you can read
about them on our website but we do
depend on you
uh to do what we do and uh you can sign
up at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code indicted again all one word
no space uh for a sizable discount and
we do an extra show every day for our
members so if you like this show my
sense is you'll like the bonus show Alex
Jones doesn't like it Howard Stern likes
it but won't pay for it but it is what
it is joinpakman.com is the place to
sign up all right listen I am not here
to sing the Praises of Mark Zuckerberg
but I have to tell you that I am
delighted by what is going on with
meta's recently launched Twitter
competitor called threads I joined
threads last night you can um you can
see my profile there I am david.pakman
on threads and I would love for you to
follow me what is this what is this all
about axios has a good article
explaining it meta's Twitter editor for
quote friendly conversation launches
early Elon musk's blunders with Twitter
are gifting Mark Zuckerberg an opportune
opening for a new rival app
threads launched last night at 7 pm
Eastern they were going to debut it
today Thursday but they ended up
debuting it early it's available on
Android and the Apple Store I don't know
what it's called now the iTunes Store I
don't know anything about iPhones I'm
sorry but it's on uh it's available on
Android and Apple phones that's for sure
um a bunch of things that Elon Musk has
done recently have particularly set up
the environment for some kind of Twitter
competitor there was this rate limit
where if you were not verified on
Twitter if you're not paying for Twitter
you can only see 600 tweets a day it's
pretty Bonker stuff then Twitter
announced that it's tweetdeck dashboard
will become available only to paying
subscribers I mean quite frankly Elon
Musk is making blunder after blunder I
know that much like with Jordan Peterson
there are people with Elon Musk that say
David if you think he's making mistakes
it's because you don't understand the
genius of what he's doing I had people
emailing me saying David uh you know
what Elon Musk is doing is actually
genius he's reducing bandwidth costs by
limiting the number of tweets that you
can see and it's all 4D chess and it's
just all completely and totally
incredible all right I just don't seem
to think that's the case my activity on
Twitter is down to almost zero and so is
that of so many of the people that I
follow because it's just become a bad
experience so in comes threads
threads is connected to meta you can log
into threads with your Instagram account
not only am I now on threads the David
packman show is on threads we're looking
at becoming early adopters when it comes
to posting our video content there we're
not exactly yet sure sure whether this
can be automated in some way from a
technical standpoint if anybody happens
to know please let us know we're working
on it and will soon be up to speed Elon
musk's comment on all of this last night
was quote it is infinitely preferable to
be attacked by strangers on Twitter then
indulge in the false happiness of hide
the pain Instagram of course referring
to the idea that threads is seeking to
be a sort of more positive environment
less about trolling and insults and this
sort of thing now what are my real
thoughts about this because as as I'm
sure you know if you know me you know
that I am not about picking the right
billionaire air whose horse I'm going to
attach my buggy to or whatever the case
may be we relying on one possible
sociopath to defeat another is not like
a thrilling and super exciting strategy
for the future of humanity I am not
naive to the undeniable reality that
meta's threads is just another attempt
to monopolize the online discourse
for-profit and control of the narrative
okay I mean like okay so Twitter has
been failing to do it recently so now in
comes Mark Zuckerberg and whatever the
case may be are we all pining for
another corporate controlled platform
not really am I concerned that what
happened on Facebook around recent
elections the spread of disinformation
coveted disinformation election
disinformation it could just take over
threads as well of course I'm concerned
about that of course I'm concerned about
that and unfortunately some of these
decentralized sort of attempts to
replace Twitter have flopped Mastodon
was one uh which I mean listen I got on
there within 10 seconds I knew it was
going nowhere I'm sorry I know people
still email me and say David when are
you getting on Mastodon I'm on it nobody
knows because there's a hundred
different servers and if you're not on
the same server you have no idea I'm on
it I listen I'm sorry I'm sorry okay I
don't think Mastodon is it blue sky I
thought was very interesting I was
concerned that by limiting the number of
new users that could sign up blue sky
was vulnerable to something like threads
coming forward I'm still on blue sky
blue sky now has announced they are
pausing new member signups I mean it's I
I still am holding out hope for blue sky
but it seems as though it's not going
particularly well so on the one hand
I am thrilled at the idea of a more
functional no rate limits no you know
all of this whacked out stuff that's
happening on Twitter I like that I think
that that's a good thing there's a
functional verification system still on
threads because it's using the Instagram
verification system I think that these
things are good on the other hand I can
only imagine that meta's real agenda
here is to continue building this uh
environment in which you've got Facebook
and WhatsApp and Instagram and threads
and they're building the metaverse and
on and on and on and meta goes in the
direction of dominating our digital
lives and and taking away autonomy and
potentially hurting democracy so I'm
curious about threads I'm on threads
we're going to start using it as a tool
to promote our content I'm skeptical I
don't know how meta is going to ensure
that threads just doesn't end up with
the exact same misinformation problems
that Facebook and Instagram quite
frankly had around elections and coveted
disinformation so find me on threads at
david.pakman the show is there at David
Pacman show it's actually small enough
still where I'm seeing everybody who's
responding to me so like on Twitter it's
a lost cause it's just totally out of
control on threads I'm actually seeing
everybody so follow me there and we'll
see what we end up doing with it cocaine
has been found at the White House and of
course this is triggering everybody that
you can imagine would be triggered let's
first start with the facts and then
we'll go on to the commentary Politico
reports suspicious powder found at the
White House when Biden was gone was
cocaine was cocaine according to
Associated Press sources Secret Service
agents were doing routine rounds on
Saturday uh Sunday when they found the
white powder in an area accessible to
tour groups not in any particular West
Wing off office the White House was
briefly evacuated Sunday evening Biden
wasn't there he was at Camp David and a
preliminary tests showed it was cocaine
according to law enforcement Secret
Service agents were doing rounds they
found the powder in this area
um the officials are not authorized to
discuss the investigation there was an
evacuation at 8 45. now you might say
why would you evacuate for coke before
they knew it was coke they thought it
could be Anthrax or who knows what it
might have been they did a rapid test
and it was indeed cocaine it was the
White House reopened and that is it now
we're going to be going through some of
the typical reactions from the right and
this includes it was Hunter Biden
imagine if this happened under Trump
Etc I want to just put out there I
received a bunch of emails from people
saying David you're not going to cover
this you're scared to cover this it's
the typical thing if a story doesn't go
with your narrative you ignore it what
narrative have I ever stated that this
would contradict have I been have I
spent the last 10 years saying folks
there are no drugs at the White House
and now cocaine at the White House has
destroyed my narrative but I don't know
why you're thinking I would ignore this
story important Lee the area is
accessible to tour groups it's an area
where people from the public walk
through it makes it a much less
interesting story if this was found in
you know the the personal residence of
Joe Biden then it might be a more
interesting story although maybe it
wouldn't be I don't know but the
reaction from the right-wing extremists
has been extreme but also sadly
predictable and we're going to talk
about it in the next segment for now I
do want to tell you about Donald Trump's
reaction to the cocaine in the White
House
failed former president Donald Trump
twice impeached twice indicted went on a
hysterical Troth Central rant over
cocaine being found at the White House
as I already told you cocaine at the
White House was found in an area
accessible to tour groups it wasn't in
Joe Biden's private bathroom it wasn't
in you know wherever these right-wingers
would love the cocaine to have been
found and Donald Trump went to Troth
Central and posted quote does anybody
really believe that the cocaine found in
the west wing of the White House very
close to the Oval Office is for the use
of anyone other than Hunter and Joe
Biden but watch the fake news media will
Stu soon start saying that the amount
found was very small and it wasn't
really cocaine but rather Common Ground
Up aspirin and the story will vanish has
deranged Jack Smith the crazy
trump-hating special prosecutor been
seen in the air area of the cocaine
he looks like a crackhead to me
this is really really crazy I I want to
remind you this is the former president
of the United States alleging that
cocaine found in the White House belongs
to the President Joe Biden and Hunter
and that the man Prosecuting him Jack
Smith
is a crackhead is a crackhead now I
think it's important to mention that
doesn't really make sense if Hunter
Biden was doing coke at the White House
I don't know that he'd be doing it in an
area accessible to the public It just
strikes me as something that he wouldn't
do but the right Wings continued
obsession with Hunter Biden is bordering
on creepy and Donald Trump's obsession
with Jack Smith is also bordering on
possibly stochastically terroristic I
don't know how long it's going to take
until someone goes after Jack Smith and
by the way Trump posted what he believed
to be Barack Obama's home address and an
armed Man actually showed up there we're
going to talk about that later not right
now so Trump losing his mind over
cocaine at the White House no evidence
that it's Hunter bidens but later in the
show we are going to talk about some of
the other wacky reactions to this bit of
news really not a major story like I
said earlier I have no reason to cover
up this story but there's also not that
much to say about it but we will look at
the Fox and Friends discussion about
Coke at the White House after this break
make sure that you were subscribed on
YouTube we are approaching 2 million
subscribers I really want you to be one
of those two million
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right a few other unhinged reactions
to cocaine found at the White House of
course in an area accessible to tour
groups people from the public who come
through here is Republican Congressman
Daryl Issa appearing on Fox News and he
is directly bringing up the hunter Biden
thing he straight up says listen uh
Hunter Biden that's someone with a
history of drug addiction they find
cocaine there
I don't know I don't know here he is by
the way there's no evidence that this
has anything to do with Hunter Biden
it's actually quite stupid to think it
does let's listen huge difference uh
when in fact all the president and then
before that vice president had to do was
make it appear as though he was behind
his son he has done that before he did
it yesterday he continues to have
somebody with a history of drug
addiction uh in the white house uh and
uh it is not a small problem that we
find cocaine after Hunter Biden's been
in the White House and people rolled
their eyes and say you know we never had
this before how could what's changed
yeah right interestingly we didn't have
it under Obama we didn't have it under
George W bush that that we knew about
but Daryl Issa is being so irresponsible
here now obviously this is another one
of these completely ridiculous
narratives that accomplishes nothing as
Republicans continue to offer absolutely
nothing by way of policy to the American
people that shouldn't be ignored
specifics aside just the fact that this
is what they're talking about
I I just to do it justice I'm not
finding any information that Hunter
Biden is is using cocaine at this point
in time uh the cocaine was found where
visitors leave their belongings
so there's really no particular reason
to say hunter Biden has anything to do
with this whatsoever and at some point
you would think let me apply a little
bit of logic here if Biden's son were
using cocaine and if he were using it at
the White House these are all claims for
which we have no evidence if all of
those things were true
why would he be doing it in the area
where visitors leave their belongings in
fact he would almost certainly not be
there the fact that this is where it was
found is essentially a guarantee this
has nothing to do with Hunter Biden but
you know they they don't they didn't do
their health care plan they didn't build
the wall they didn't solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict they didn't
do any of those things so what they've
got is Biden's son is in the White House
and he's snorting lines of coke while he
is there now let's go to the next
element of this Fox and Friends host
Brian Kilmeade
went further with the cocaine in the
White House story
he went to was there fentanyl in the
cocaine and hilariously Steve Ducey who
occasionally will actually behave like a
normal person and apply critical
thinking to what is said by his co-hosts
he just is kind of like
what the f are you talking about
fentanyl what what check out this
hilarious exchange where Brian Kilmeade
introduces fentanyl with no evidence and
then Steve Ducey is like wait what what
are you talking about we don't know if
this fentanyl on that cocaine too that's
the problem uh you saw that uh Robert De
Niro's grandson just died uh fentanyl
was in whatever substance he bought at
the White House
[Laughter]
starting to get get annoyed so you can
tell from the body language here
kill Mead is annoying annoyed he is
annoying but kill Mead is annoyed that
yet again Steve Ducey is interrupting
his rants
Steve do see clearly is getting a little
bit irritated that his co-host Brian
kilmead is constantly saying insane
things I'm going to go back we're only
10 seconds in let's play it from the
beginning and again kill Mead visibly
annoyed that Ducey is like what are you
talking about dude we don't know if this
fennel on that cocaine too that's the
problem uh you saw that Robert De Niro's
grandson just died uh fentanyl was in
whatever substance he bought at the
White House fentanyl at the White House
they don't know what's in it he thought
he was buying one drug fentanyl was in
it do we know that fentanyl's in this
cocaine
at CBS said this could have been a
non-magnetic powder that could have made
it through Anthrax this is a huge
national security threat in the Press
well they're just slapping it off but
what would you expect I I hate to tell
people like I really do but you know it
non-magnetic powder yeah it's okay it's
a threat you do they do tours at the
White House I mean are are we really
what's the expectation right when Kaylee
mcinanny says this is a big national
security threat and it starts to be a
sort of an attack on security measures
at the White House if you have a few
grains of one of these non-magnetic
magnetic powders in the bottom of a
pocket
um No One's Gonna find that no one you
can get wanded with a metal detector and
you can get a pat down and you can
answer a questionnaire I mean a few
grains of this stuff is going to be very
difficult to find it's not unique to Joe
Biden it's not a particular failure of
security under the Biden Administration
or any of these things but the look on
Steve ducey's face is really something
else there
um okay I think we've said everything we
have to say about Biden and uh cocaine
at the White House I just I don't know
that there's anything else to say about
it there was cocaine found there's
nothing linking it to anybody in the
Biden Administration right Wingers are
going crazy saying it's hunter bidens or
it's some bigger issue we've talked
about it we're going to take a break
we're going to move on and get on to
other things
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well the
first 24 hours of the children's book
have been insane it is the number one
best seller in its category on Amazon
this is crazy I don't even understand
what's happening but I'll try to explain
it to you uh I wrote a kids book okay
here is the book think like a detective
it's just a fun book to start
introducing critical thinking Concepts
to kids what is evidence how do we know
that something's true this sort of thing
um there's jokes in it that are more for
adults as well you will see that there
is a boy named Ronald there's a boy
named Ronald on one page
who looks a lot like a particularly uh
uh terrible former president and Ronald
lied about the number of kids at his
birthday party you get the joke okay you
get it we started making this available
yesterday on Amazon paperback and then
Kindle pre-orders all the Kindle ones
will come out on Saturday it's just the
way it works I had absolutely no idea
the way that this was going to go
and from the number of complaints I
received about the book you would think
that it would go terribly for example
someone wrote to me and said David this
is too advanced for young kids it's
really more for high school students I
don't think so it really is a kids book
yes if you're six or seven
you're going to need to have your you
know adult or guardian or someone read
the book to you I get that and explain
it but this is not a book for high
schoolers no this is this is a book for
kids but someone said David this is too
advanced someone wrote to me and said
David the picture of the kid detective
on the front the kid should be a
minority it looks like the kid is white
so I'm not gonna buy the book oh boy
David the book should not be sold by
Amazon it should be sold by someone else
I get the Amazon stuff okay the the
reality is that we're not looking to buy
a thousand of these and then ship them
out ourselves Amazon's print on demand
is really convenient our main thing is
this show we needed convenience okay but
I'm with you someone else said David
this book is not accessible globally
because it is only in English that's
true we only wrote the book in English
I'm sorry someone else wrote it and said
David the book should not have been done
with AI illustrations even if we did use
AI illustrations as a base and then edit
them ourselves that was wrong someone
else wrote to me said David you
shouldn't have the Kindle available for
pre-order it should be available now
like the paperback it wasn't our choice
there the Amazon system requires some
lead time before the Kindle orders are
filled I'm sorry I'm sorry but we have
persevered
and this is insane the book is the
number one best seller in Amazon's
children's reference and non-fiction
section I
it is absolutely stunning to me we have
fulfill I don't know how many paperbacks
have been ordered I only know how many
have been shipped
108 paperbacks have already been shipped
and many more have been ordered
232 people
have pre-ordered the digital Kindle
version we have received orders from the
UK Germany Italy Australia Canada
um it's it's just incredible it's
incredible that all being said
I do want to go through and just show
you some amazing messages and reviews
that we got Braden wrote in with a
really good idea and said potential
children's book ban David huge fan of
the new children's book I think it's a
great idea plan on buying it however how
long do you think it will take for
Florida to ban it for woke
indoctrination I'd love to hear your
thoughts my friends I hope someone tries
to ban this book people have been
writing to me saying they're going to
gift the book to a bunch of libraries I
hope a library rejects it I hope someone
I have teachers writing to me saying
David I'm going to use this book in
class I'm going to read this book to my
students the book is not political yes
it makes fun of trump okay but it's not
a political book little kids wouldn't
even realize that it's like an adult
joke I would love it
if parents go crazy because their
teacher read this book to students in
class I would love it if a school
library and who the hell knows Tennessee
tries to ban the book I hope they try to
ban the book let's try to make it happen
I think it would be a great story okay
now some really great reviews already on
Amazon and please remember if you order
the book please review it it's so
important it's the number one thing that
determines how it will do
um okay X here's one review excellent
secular homeschooling resource I
homeschool my learning disabled son and
I'm excited for this book all students
should learn how to think I can't wait
for the author to publish books about
this subject for teens and adults
beautiful review
next review will bring tears to your
eyes
I see what you did there wonderful book
for our Future Leaders save the country
have your children learn about critical
thinking at ASAP
sir I write this as a big strong man I
have tears in my eyes with the thought
of giving this book to my children
beautiful beautiful message folks uh I
don't know how far this is going to go
it really started kind of as a goof but
it's now the best seller in its category
on Amazon you can get it on Kindle you
can get it on paperback buy copies
distribute them to libraries give them
to your kids teachers say here's
something to read
davidpackman.com book let's keep going
as we push this into more countries and
please review the book let me know what
you think Etc all right I said we were
moving on from the hunter Biden cocaine
story which has nothing to do with
Hunter Biden like they're calling it The
Hunter Biden cocaine story even though
there is no connection to Hunter Biden I
told you earlier cocaine found at the
White House in an area where Public
tours go through
and multiple Fox News hosts suggesting
it might have something to do with
Hunter Biden despite the fact that there
is no such evidence here is another
segment from this morning that's why I'm
only getting to it now Julie Banderas
interviewing former Congressman Jason
Chaffetz and she does the listen we're
not saying it was Hunter's cocaine but
we're asking questions that nobody else
is even willing to ask I think they
already know where it is I think they're
trying to wait for the DNA evidence that
doesn't happen in just a half a day or a
day but the Secret Service I do believe
knows at this point who this person is I
mean if you look at the way that they're
handling it right off the bat they're
making it seem suspicious we're not
point I mean we're just asking questions
the reporters that are there in the
Press pool right but then if you it's
like when Tucker asks questions do brown
people make the country dirtier and
poorer we're just asking the question
look at all the other networks for
example all the major broadcast networks
last night they all LED with the cocaine
found at the White House not one one
broadcast mentioned the name Hunter
Biden now we're not saying it's Hunter
Biden we're calling it for what it is
the president's son is a former crack
cocaine addict and he's supposed to be
clean he just he was given a slap on the
wrist for charges that should have been
felony charges why because he's the
president's son so preferential
treatment obviously is a very sensitive
topic when it comes to his son and
indeed cocaine was found in an area in
the white house where Hunter Biden has
visited so of course that's going to be
a question and there's no room for
joking about it all the other networks
making these stupid jokes there's no
laughing matter crack cocaine addiction
is serious and this is a serious drug
that was found in our White House
yes and I I heard one of those reporters
talking about well nobody got hurt what
about the development transport in all
of the other I mean that is just a
ridiculous he doesn't even know what
he's talking about so listen
um I got an email from a lawyer this
morning
who said you know David it is not yet at
this point
but it is starting to border on
it's not inconceivable that Hunter Biden
may be able to argue that some of these
statements are defamatory now Julie
Banderas is being sort of careful and
that she's saying we're not saying it's
Hunter Biden's cocaine which of course
is code for we sort of are saying it
we're certainly implying it if nothing
else but okay putting that aside
a lawyer wrote to me and said if this
went another step further Hunter Biden
may be able to uh Sue Fox News for
defamation I don't expect it to happen
but it is compelling stuff the latest
news by the way is that there is going
to be uh that apparently they have tapes
there are cameras that are going to be
able to figure this out and there's a
report from Reuters
cameras visitor logs searched after
cocaine found at White House and that
now it may uh we may know exactly who
brought the cocaine I am not a betting
man you all know that I I really I
really just don't bet I just save and
invest my money I don't bet but if I
were a betting man okay my bet is that
the cocaine is not Hunter bidens if the
cocaine is Hunter Biden's
write to me tell me what I should do
I'll do something if the cocaine is
Hunter bidens I'll I don't know donate
to some drug thing or I don't know but
if I were a betting man I would say this
is not Hunter Biden's cocaine Mike Pence
is running for president you may not
have known that because his campaign is
extraordinarily low energy although I
will tell you he is actually ticking up
a little bit in uh Republican polling
we'll get to that in a moment a visibly
Disturbed woman confronted Mike Pence at
a rally
sorry this is not a rally at a I don't
know what to call this at an event where
he spoke to a small crowd a crazy woman
stood up and said it is his fault that
Biden is President because Biden is only
President because Mike Pence didn't
quote send the election back to the
States what do they mean by that I don't
actually think they know I'll explain
that in a moment but here is this woman
saying it is your fault that Biden is
here because you didn't do it you didn't
reject the election results let's take a
listen if it wasn't for your vote
we would not have Joe Biden in the white
house right Joe Biden shouldn't be there
and all those wonderful things that you
and Trump were doing together would be
continuing and this country would be on
the right path
do you ever second guess yourself that
was a constitutional right that you had
to send those folks back to the States
Diddy it was not like you were going to
personally elect him
we all know by the number of votes that
were there who won that election
Constitution is very clear
my job was to oversee assistant
Congressman where objections could be
heard
make sure that objections would be
recognized so we would hear whatever
evidence of running debate there was
but the Constitution says you open and
count the votes no more no less the
Constitution affords No Authority the
vice president or anyone else to reject
votes or return votes to the states Mike
Pence is correct here on this issue it
doesn't mean I agree with him on
abortion or taxes but he is correct on
this issue
never been done before
should never be done in the future I'm
sorry man but that's actually what the
Constitution says no vice president
American history ever asserted The
Authority that you have been convinced
that I had
and I want to tell you in all due
respect I said before I said when I
announced president Trump was wrong
about my authority that day and he's
still wrong Mike Pence is completely
correct
he's correct think about it for a second
like we'll we'll get into the law in a
moment the law is clear but you don't
even need to look at the law just apply
Common Sense apply Common Sense directly
to your forehead and think about it what
does it mean to send it back to the
States the states send their results
Arizona sends their results and they say
Biden got more votes so Arizona's
electoral votes go to Joe Biden great
Penn stands up and says no I don't
accept these I am sending these results
back to the states and the state goes
okay uh Joe Biden won we're sending it
back to you again
only if you think that upon sending it
back to the States someone will
intervene and send fake electors which
they wanted to do
could you get it into your brain that's
sending it back to the states is a real
thing now if you look at the
Constitution Mike Pence is completely
correct the Constitution the law give
the vice president the role of opening
and Counting electoral votes that have
been certified by each state the
president the vice president rather
functioning as the president of the
senate in that situation has no
authority to change or reject the
electoral votes that have been sent
there by the states if Mike Pence had
tried to do that it would have violated
the Democratic principles and the norms
and the law of American government
Trump got this idea from that Infamous
legal Memo from John Eastman the
deranged lawyer law professor who was
advising Trump what might you be able to
do and the Eastman memo had a number of
ideas this was one of them
and as far as this idea is concerned the
memo argued Pence can use an obscure law
called The Electoral count Act of 1887
to reject some of the electoral votes
and create a situation where no
candidate has a majority in other words
if Pence rejects enough Biden states
that neither candidate gets to 270 then
it would throw the election to the House
of Representatives
that interpretation was widely rejected
by every serious legal expert historian
and lawmaker from both the Republican
and Democratic parties as
unconstitutional baseless and a
completely wrong-headed interpretation
of the 1887 electoral count act so the
woman's wrong it's interesting that
she's even at a pence event I don't know
if she considers herself a supporter of
Pence you'd think not if she thinks that
this is what Pence should have done
presumably she supports towards Trump
and not Mike Pence on this issue and
Mike Pence I think is a disgusting guy
in just about every way on this issue
Mike Pence's uncontroversial uh uh
non-controversially and incontrovertibly
um stating what the law is and that is
it and for that I guess he deserves
praise the bar is that low with this
Republican party that we can praise him
for that we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P you can call any
time of day here is a caller who is
calling me out how do I care about the
environment and yet I flew
on an airplane
okay let's take a listen
bagel
did I hear how many flights you've been
doing
500 gallons per hour
please put your carbon footprint usage
next to you super cool I voted blue
check mark yeah a check mark I've never
displayed
and when you see Pete the incompetent
fell in our holes in some serious
filling
a little bit of that hot asphalt
breastfeeding Road reparations
should we go a long way to drive my
pretty little Tesla on
Tesla
you do okay work but you you got to work
some things out on your
on on your genealogical trees you got
from coughing up to do I think that that
is anti-Semitic I've got to figure some
things out work some things out on my
genealogical tree I can only imagine
that's an anti-semitic comment
anyways other than that you're somewhat
acceptable
bye let's see how much fuel you burnt
last year you silly willy okay listen so
I've heard this before okay you care
about the environment and yet you still
utilize transportation and purchase food
to metabolize into energy to sustain
Homo sapiens I mean listen
um caring about the environment doesn't
mean you give up every form of
transportation or any activity that has
a carbon foot run okay and I don't know
that anybody holds themselves or others
to that standard caring about the
environment means you advocate for more
sustainable and efficient Alternatives
renewable energy sources carbon offsets
public transit
Etc and you've got these right Wingers
who love to criticize leftists so you
flew in an airplane it's a logical
fallacy you flew in an airplane
it's an appeal to hypocrisy what they
are actually doing and uh this is when
you try to discredit an argument by
pointing out its inconsistency that the
person making the argument is
inconsistent you are are uh inconsistent
because you say you care about the
environment yet you drove a car
or you traveled on an airplane they
don't actually address the argument
itself it doesn't actually invalidate
the argument that we are making
the argument they seem to be making
implicitly is people on the left
shouldn't have cars of any kind they
should never travel by airplane cell
phones have conflict minerals I guess no
cell phones plus the cell phone gets
shipped so that's it gets shipped on an
airplane you know so that that that's a
carbon footprint you I guess according
to these people have to live like an
ascetic to really be a consistent
liberal or something like that the
reality of course is people on the left
drive cars and have cell phones they're
not Hypocrites by their very nature
simply because they care about the
environment we are using the available
technology and infrastructure that
Society provides should I be biking to
my brother's wedding in California
should I not be going because I'm on the
left and I care about the environment or
whatever the case may be and by the way
I'm aware of the negative impacts of
those products and I support efforts to
reduce that electric vehicles is a step
recycling is a step ethical sourcing is
another I know people will write to me
and they'll say David some forms of
recycling
actually have a larger carbon footprint
depending on how it's done I'm aware of
that recycling when it reduces the
carbon footprint liberals who drive cars
or have cell phones aren't responsible
for the economic uh environmental rather
damage that corporations cause by virtue
of their products and services we want
to hold the corporations accountable for
their actions we want to pressure them
to adopt more environmentally friendly
practices and policies and all of it so
when I have a phone or I fly on an
airplane I'm not ignoring the
environmental problems uh I am actively
involved in raising awareness about
those problems donating campaigning for
more sustainable options and solutions
and in fact we often use those tools to
raise awareness I use my phone to get
the word out about these things that I
believe I sometimes draw dive or fly to
events at which I advocate for these
things so this appeal to hypocrisy
fallacy from these people who have
absolutely nothing to offer on their own
of any substance or productivity uh they
barely deserve attention so okay I
addressed it here now we can go back to
ignoring them we have such a great bonus
show for you today a David Pac-Man
membership coach six bucks a month it
does but if you use a coupon code it's
cheaper we are going to talk about the
hottest day in history which took place
this week on today's bonus show and by
the way the record is going to be broken
again we are going to talk about Central
Park five member Youssef Salam winning
the New York City council's Democratic
primary and we are also going to talk
about radical and repugnant Republican
Congressman Matt Gates proposing to end
Cannabis Testing for the military
something I actually agree with why is
he doing it well maybe he just believes
it's the right thing all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
you can access the bonus show with a
number of different machines we're doing
a class action loss
right in all seriousness it doesn't have
to end right now there is more show
available today you don't have to wait
until tomorrow sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and I will be
joined by producer Pat see you then or
we'll be back here tomorrow
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors I will simply
never have time to read all of the
non-fiction books I'd like to read so I
use short form the world's best guide to
non-fiction books so I can learn more
faster unlike other platforms short form
provides valuable analysis chapter by
chapter to give you a deeper
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below